what is your reading of the situation on
the ground right now well there's three
big pieces of activity taking place in
the Northeast there's what's becoming a
static Fierce fight and we'll come on to
that in a second in the South and
operational silence it sounds ominous
and I'll talk about that as well and
then the referendum that we've just
heard about as well okay so what kind of
fighting are we seeing on the ground
particularly when we look at the donbath
region the donbass region you know it's
the area that's been fought over most
hotly since the um start of the war 200s
and some um 12 days back now
um
the ukraines have done particularly well
over the last last few weeks I've heard
about strategic successes securing of
the the the the heart cave and the north
operational success isium isium was a
key logistical node for the Russians
that's now moved back into the Ukrainian
hands but where we're seeing the real
Fierce fighting now is the pocket just
here
um we saw that fought over in May um
Winston severe dunesque and if you can
relate and think about how horrific it
must have been the first world war
they're the type of fighting that we're
seeing now it's Fields it's forests it's
streets and casualties on both sides are
some 50 and what about the southern
regions
operational style silence what does that
mean well
it tells preparation of the battlefield
is what I would call it as I was once in
an intelligence officer
and the ukrainians are taking time now
to understand
what they must do next understand where
they should have the most effect they've
got some excellent weapon right now from
NATO forces how that should be used and
then they've also got some very large
geographical problems to get past the
river systems there are very very
significant and they're also buying time
as well to get prepared for the next
stage we're starting to see now as well
some special forces activity from
Ukraine the penetration of Russian lanes
and that would go hand in hand with the
disruption of the referendum which
started yesterday afternoon what is your
take on on the referendum
well first of all the intelligence
reports are telling me that there's only
some 15 to 25 turnout and a talent
supports are also telling me that it is
a coerced turnout so therefore the
legitimacy is without a doubt in doubt
but are you concerned about the fear of
escalation as Sally Lockwood told us
from Ukraine if Russia now declares
these this territory as theirs and
Ukraine is is attacking that territory
particularly with Western weapons what
happens then that's exactly it so we
heard at the start of the week Putin
talked about
um the doctrine renters nuclear
capability
in that it will not get used if there's
no infringement on Russian soil and
that's not changed for many many years
of Doctrine and we know that well of
course if the ground becomes Russian
soil that then creates a debate about
how the doctor then kicks in from the
regime's perspective
and then we're starting to talk about
now could there be a very quick
escalation in order to de-escalate as
quickly as possible is one out is one
out outcome
um now is the time for talks and
certainly before that would take place
okay you're back with us in the next
hour but for now Forbes thank you very
much force McKenzie joining us there